let's get more on our breaking news now
and that is that the government ordered
review into smoking has recommended
raising the legal age for buying
cigarettes in england by one year every
year well let's go to newsroom where
madeleine radcliffe is standing by with
the details at madeleine tell us more
yes well these are the radical solutions
um from the independent review
commissioned by the health secretary
satya david in an effort to reduce the
number of smokers in england currently
there are about six million smokers and
and the main one that headline is of
course raising the smoking age um up one
year every year it was thought it might
go straight up to be raised straight up
to 21 the legal age you can buy
cigarettes they're not doing that
instead they're following the model set
by new zealand which has been widely
praised for its anti-smoking legislation
it will go up one year every year and
that will create effectively a
generation of people who aren't allowed
to buy cigarettes um
so that's the big one the other they say
there are four key recommendations out
of 15 in total one of their other big
ones is a huge amount of money 125
million pounds a year invested in its
smoke free by 2030 agenda that is the
idea that they want to get the number of
smokers in britain down to about five
percent of the population effectively
smoke free
and so a huge amount of money will go
into that potentially raised by a
polluter pays levy on tobacco companies
that money will then be invested into
the nhs specifically one of its other
big recommendations the third key one to
encourage switching from cigarettes to
vaping and e-cigarettes and providing
more information about the benefits of
switching and of course all the other
services the nhs can provide across its
different
parts and bodies to encourage people to
smoke but some of the other
recommendations and they're really
interesting the idea that you might need
a special tobacco license for retailers
to sell tobacco products or
increasing duty on tobacco products all
designed to make it harder for people to
smoke in addition to that of course key
key recommendation that this smoking age
will go up one year every year but now
all of these recommendations are going
to have to be consulted upon before they
end up as policy eventually